steve is with us in Cincinnati hi Steve
how are you better than I deserve what's
up hey I appreciate you taking my call I
have a question concerning I recently
came into a lump sum of money I mean
just under 20 million dollars and my
question to you is I've never been one
to have nowhere near this type of money
and I want to make sure it lasts for
generations and their rights I mean my
grandkids grandkids grandkids they have
money so how much are you getting nope
this is just under 20 million holy word
you get it
well close relative my I want to say too
much behave because no I wouldn't don't
say too much it's an inheritance though
right but but I guess a close relative
of my owns a company and it had like
maybe three locations this company's all
in the state of Ohio but it's three
locations and they were able to sell it
and I thought making the sale they are
giving me I work with them but they're
giving me 20 minutes we're just under 20
million oh my and I know you give to my
church yeah and I know to pay off my dad
and so what was your income prior to
this my wife and I together make right
around 90 okay all right well there's
two or three aspects to this the first
one is you know you just because this
did not come up on you gradually and
steadily over a period of time
it's an emotional and a spiritual
whiplash you get I mean it's just like
your lottery winter kind of you know
right and and you can really make
mistakes in that setting if you're not
careful you have to be very altra
careful because this is what we call
sudden wealth and sudden wealth is the
most dangerous kind people most often
lose it and I am trying to scare you
okay
and so the way you need to look at it
you said your church so you're a person
of faith is that you have been given
this tremendous management opportunity
to manage this money for God
now if you were going let's pretend that
this wasn't quote/unquote your money and
instead you were managing it for someone
else your relative called you up and
said hey I'm gonna move you I'm gonna
give you a promotion instead of doing
what you're doing I wanted you to manage
20 million dollars for me and you'll be
going well crap I've never done that
before how am I supposed to do that and
the first thing that go through your
head is I've got to put together a team
of people to help me make decisions that
are smarter than me about money and can
advise me not make my decisions for me I
don't need a new babysitter but I've got
to put I've got to get some experts
around me it's like if someone came to
me and said Dave you need to build a
website man I can't even spell website
I'd have to put a team of people around
me so I have a you know 160 folks on our
tech team working here doing programming
and other things that I can't even spell
and so you have to put a team of people
around you that know things that you
don't know to inform you well enough
that you can make decisions because you
are called to manage this okay okay
now and that's thing one and that sounds
like this it sounds like an estate
planner it's an insurance person that's
an insurance broker that represents
several different companies it's an
investment broker get our endorsed local
provider on your little council that
you're forming and you need a tax
attorney or a a top-flight top-drawer
CPA one of the two so taxes estate
planning insurance and investments
that's your first four people you put on
the on the council and they have to be
able to explain their area of expertise
in such a way that you can understand it
to keep their job okay if they don't
have the heart of a teacher and you
don't grasp it you fire them and get you
somebody that can talk to you where you
understand it because some of these
twerps are arrogant and they're gonna
talk down to you but you're the ones got
20 million bucks they don't right so
it's your job to do that now that's the
first thing the second thing is so get a
counsel in the multitude of counsel
there's safety the Bible says the second
thing is go slow he who hastens to be
rich will not go unpunished
Oh slow and number three don't put money
in anything ever unless you know how it
works okay and if you don't happen right
now you don't know how a lot of things
work so you're pretty limited just be
real simple and don't let people act
like you're not sophisticated and you
know what my answer would be if I were
in your shoes and they said oh you need
to do this is what's well I'm not
sophisticated enough to do that right
now I've got to learn more about that
for I can do it I'm just gonna move slow
I'm gonna move slow I'm gonna move slow
I don't mind let me tell you I met with
an NF you know how many NFL players I
meet with that are broke you've heard
this right man but I met with one the
other day I met with on the other day
that had ten million dollars you know
what the ten million dollars was put in
cash I was sitting in CDs and he was
ashamed I said don't be ashamed you got
ten million dollars the other guy's lost
theirs don't be ashamed it's awesome
it's in CDs it's not very sophisticated
you got some learning to do but don't be
ashamed dude you won the race
touchdown you know so you know yeah just
CDs is fine for a while until you
understand what you're doing go slow
understand it put a council in place
hold on I'm gonna have Kelly pick up I'm
gonna send you a copy of the book the
legacy journey
you